[Music]
this place is really a place where we
think that the value comes from the
exchanges that the value is in the
different
components of our economy of the large
industrial groups that have made
France proud  SMEs and
innovative exporters in the
territories and start-ups that come to
shake up technologies and
finally I believe
that you are the best
incarnation tonight that basically a strategy an
ecosystem is the meeting of its
different components obviously
the  interest in artificial intelligence,
it goes through all its
components and so here is just to
tell you that you are at home here and
that this whole evening will only
further confirm our commitment
to the state to ensure that these
different these  different actors
you invent collectively is the
best way to ensure that
we talk to each other about this major subject
and q  that we make loans a great
economic success in the years to come
[Music]